in unseren insight geht es diese woche
um sex fitness ikone pamela reiss
spricht jetzt erstmals öffentlich über
ihr erstes mal in ihrem podcast schau ma
mal den sie gemeinsam mit ihrem bruder
dennis aufnimmt berichtet sie folgendes
mein erstes mal war glaube ich mit 18
auf jeden fall ziemlich spät für die
heutige jugend was mir aber dann in dem
moment nicht peinlich war beim ersten
mal sex war ich fast stolz darauf dass
ich nicht so offen gesagt rom geholt
habe wie so einige andere aus meiner
klasse schon famila spricht auch ganz
offen über den moment als es passierte
es war unbeholfen bei mir war es auf
jeden fall in dem bett in dem ich heute
noch schlafen
für ihn war es aber nicht das erste mal
es hat mir auf jeden fall nicht wie ich
habe auch nicht blutet das weiß ich noch
dann erzählt wie es für sie war
meinst du irgendjemand kommt zum
orgasmus beim ersten mal kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen
ich kam auf jeden fall nicht aber das
habe ich auch gar nicht erwartet
außerdem verriet die 24-jährige dass sie
gar nicht richtig aufgeklärt worden ist
ihre vorstellung vom sex ich habe damals
nicht gewusst dass das männliche glied
steif wird und ich habe mich immer
gefragt wie das geht das es dann da
reingeht fans idee beschreibt sie so
pendelt dann so über dem loch und dann
muss man abwarten dass man den richtigen
moment findet dass es rein geht dagegen
war im gegensatz zur familie reiz
ziemlich früh dran
der youtube star erzählt in einem ihrer
videos das habe ich noch nie erzählt und
hat das auch irgendwie nie vor zu
erzählen
mein erstes mal hatte ich tatsächlich
mit 14 sehr sehr jung mit meinem
damaligen ersten freund im nachhinein
denke ich mir ich hätte ruhig noch ein
bisschen warten können bereuen tut die
26-jährige diese entscheidung nicht es
sei nichts was sie als fehler bezeichnen
würde
seit zwei jahren ist sie glücklich mit
ehemann eugen verheiratet ein erstes mal
hoch drei erlebte katja karlovic der
youtube star machte stadt romantischen
blümchensex ganz andere erfahrungen und
steht ganz offen dazu dass ihr erstes
mal nicht ganz klassisch abliest denn
bei ihrem ersten sex handelt es sich
direkt um einen dreier
aber nicht nur deutsche promis erzählen
von ihren ersten sexuellen erfahrungen
auch internationale hollywood-star
verfehlen ihre stories sängerin miley
cyrus hatte erstes mal mit ihrem
späteren ehe und jetzt ex mann liam
hemsworth
dieser wusste angeblich gar nicht dass
er damals
die 16-jährige entjungfert sie ließ ihn
in dem glauben schon mal mit einem
bekannten geschlafen zu haben
diese lüge kam dann erst zehn jahre
danach in dem podcast koller der die ans
tageslicht bei dem ehemaligen teenie
traumpaar selena gomez und justin bieber
passierte es 2011 ganz romantisch beim
kurzurlaub in form springs thorsten
bestätigte später in einem interview
dass elina ihm die jungfräulichkeit
geschenkt hätte lieber damals 19 und er
17 jahre alt
mein co moderator von troschke ist heute
leider nicht dabei aber er sendet euch
liebe grüße und erzählt uns direkt mal
von seinem ersten mal das erste mal das
ist wirklich ein tolles thema aber auch
ein schwieriges ich kann aus meiner
erfahrung sagen ja es war wie alle sagen
die man das erste mal macht das war
nicht gut das hat nicht so viel spaß
gemacht aber wenn man dran bleibt da
wird immer besser und macht mir spaß und
ich will sagen jetzt gehört zu den
besten und habe jedes mal super viel
spaß dass mein tipp an euch ganz locker
angehen und das wird schon
[Musik]